لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا تنضم الي من
الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن وهي
عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق
الانسان دكتوره هويدا اهلا وسهلا بك الى
هذه التغطيه نريد منك بدايه اطلاله اليوم
على المشهد الاستشفائي في السودان عموما
وفي الخرطوم خصوصا مع دخول هذه المواجهات
اسبوع الثالث
السلام عليكم اولا الم
[موسيقى]
جد والخسري لقناتكم لتخطيتها المستمره
وحقيقه انا اتحدث عن منطقه شرق النيل
ومستشفى البان جديد اللي هو المستشفى
الوحيد الموجود في منطقه شرق النيل لا زال
يعمل ونحن نعمل في ظروف صحيه صعبه للغايه
لازلنا نستقبل اعداد كبيره من المصابين
وعدات كبيره من مرضى الاخرين وحقيقه لا
نستطيع تقديم الخدمه كما يجب يعني احنا
بنقدم
الاسعافات الاوليه فقط يعني نحن داخل غرفه
العمليات حتى لا نستطيع
ان نعمل برابر او ستاندر يعني احنا حتى
التعقيم لا يتم بالطريقه كما يجب ان يقوم
بها التعقيم لكثره العمليات ولكثره
الاصابات وحتى بعد ان نقوم بمساعده المرضى
على تقديم الخدمات الاوليه لا نعرف اين
نوجههم يعني اكثر المصابين احنا يتم نقلهم
الى ولايه اخرى يعني الان احنا عاده
نحول المصابين الى
ولايه الجزيره مدينه مدنيه
وحقيقه لا ندري يعني المخاطر التي تقابلهم
بالطريق يعني هناك مخاطر كثيره ربما في
طريقهم الى مدني ربما يعني يتعرضوا
للمخاطر الوضع يزداد هو ان والكوادر
الطبيه
يعني
لانه الموجوده معي بمنطقه شرق النيل وهي
المستشفى الوحيد الذي يقدم خدمه الجراحه
والنساء والتوليد والعظام
الكوادر الصحيه اصبحت مرهقه للغايه حقيقه
وعندي عدد من الاطباء الان هو اصبح مريضا
يعني وهو يعمل وهو يعني يرتاح
نعطيهم السوائل الوريديه ويعودوا للعمل
مره اخرى
دكتوره هويدا بالنسبه الى موضوع المياه
والكهرباء يعني
متوافره في في المشافي التي ما زالت تعمل
هذا واحد كمان في كلام يعني
اكثر من منظمه دوليه المخاوف من تفشي او
بيئه مثل الملاريا والكوليرا هل بداتم
تلحظوا اي حالات من ذلك ام لا هذه مبالغات
لا اساس لها من الصحه
لكن نتوقعها بكثر على فكره وتوقع التهابات
للزروع لمصابيع العمليات
وعمليات القيصريه نحن الان نقوم بعدد من
العمليات القيصريه للنساء الحوامل اتوقع
ان تنتهيب هذه العمليات والجروح لاننا
نعمل في ظروف صعبه
ان تنتهيب هذه الجروح
اتمنى اتمنى من وزاره الصحه ان تقوم في
بدورها بتقديم الخدمات يعني عليها توفير
الوقود والكهرباء على الاجل يعني نحن في
استلمنا جزء بسيط من وزاره الصحه من
المعينات وهناك في عدد من المنظمات
يعني ولكن تعرض وطول هذا الامداد الينا
صعبه يعني نحن متصل بهم ويقولون لنا يعني
هذه المعينات متوفره لكن كيف تصل الينا في
منطقه شرق النيل يعني نحن من الخوف كيف
تصل الينا هذه المعينه الصحيه نعاني من
عدم توفر الوقوداع الكهرباء داخل غرفه
العمليات
طب بالنسبه الى الكوادر الطبيه قلتم انكم
تعانون هل الا يوجد لديكم مثلا اي خطه
طوارئ يعني
تكون بشكل او باخر كفيله بسد هذا النقص ام
لا يعني هذا النقص لا يمكن سده دكتوره
هويدا
نعمل نداءات في صفحاتنا
وللجان الاحيائي على فكره يعني يساعدوننا
كثيرا الرجال الاحياء بالقرب من المستشفى
لنبحث عن اطباء وممرضين وسترات الذين
يسكنون قريبا من المستشفى حتى يعني لا
يتعرضوا للضرب والقذف في يوميا يعلم يصل
الينا عدد من الممرضين لكن حقيقه يعني حتى
في غرفه العمليات لا يوجد لدينا اخصائي
تخدير يعني
احنا بناخذ عالي جدا على فكره يعني بنستغل
العمليه بمساعده فني تخدير والنواب يعني
حتى الان ليس لدينا اخصائيه تقدير بغرفه
العمليات منذ 15 يوم
طيب بالنسبه الى المنظمات الدوليه التي
كانت عاده يعني تعمل في اكثر من منطقه
ومدينه في السودان وتقدم
خدمات
تحديدا خدمات طبيه وادويه هل لديكم اي
داله الان اتصالات معها وهل وعدتكم
بالمساعده
نعم نعم هنالك اتصال دائما عدد من
المنظمات وفي عدد من المنظمات الان وفرت
الينا امداد
ونحن على فكره لصعوبه الموقف اخذنا هذا
الخطر على انفسنا والان ارسلنا عدد من
الشباب
لقطع الكبري المنشيه والذهاب الى الخرطوم
لاستلام هذه المعينات لكن حقيقه نحن الان
نعيش في قلق تام لا ندري هل سيصلون ام لا
يعني
من الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن عضو
منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات